annahme ist nicola larini freute ich
wünsche euch ein wundervolles neues jahr
2003 ich hoffe ihr seid ein silvester
gut rein gerutscht
und mich ausgeruht
ja wir statt auf jeden fall ganz
entspannt ins neue jahr mit einer ganz
normalen
reaktion auf das video die 20 meist
gesehenen tecdax aller zeiten von
wissens werde ich frage mich aber auch
ein video von mir mitarbeiter nötig war
langsam luca ihn gerade noch ein neues
video hofft der nummer 20 beginnen wir
direkt mit einem tick tock das zeigt und
dass die plattform nicht nur der reinen
unterhaltung dient und verluste videos
sorgt ja
das mache ich mir kommen die gott in
diesem video von nest ines der über 25
millionen follower hat und seine arbeit
in einer tankstelle filmt sieht man wie
ein obdachloser mann vor der tür der
tankstelle steht jeder stick so kann ich
sogar auch gesehen
es ist halt so brutal wie die homepage
bei vielen leuten zu emma
unterschiedlich ist aber ein paar
gleiche videos kriegt jeder immer und
offensichtlich nicht genug geld für
essen dabei hat anstatt den mann jedoch
wegzuschicken bittet nest ines ihn
spontan herein und stellt ihm ein volles
menü aus essen und trinken komplett
umsonst zur verfügung man fragt sich
dann natürlich auch immer habe ich auch
damals einige kommentare unter dem tisch
doch gesehen ob das alles release oder
auch gefegt wurde aber wenn es will ist
einfach zu
neugierig kann ich bin ja ist übrigens
gerade mal zwei tage hatte ich habe
schon ein bild auf instagram hochgeladen
wieder rückwärts ja ungefähr genauso
vier klicks hat dieses video bekommen
das zeigt dass die dreharbeiten
[Musik]
hat aber nicht nur lustige videos haben
die chance viral zu gehen oder immer
recht es einfach ein vermeintlich
normales naturschauspiel im richtigen
moment aus der richtigen perspektive zu
filmen nach 256
ich muss gott mehr in diesem clip zeigt
er nicht nur welch erstaunliche
resultate man mit einem einsam stiften
erreichen kann es hat ihm außerdem dabei
geholfen mit fast zehn millionen
followern einen der größten kunst kanäle
der welt aufzubauen wie kriegen leute es
hin mit so einem stift solche
wunderwerke herzustellen
weil sie was ich schaffen wenn ich in
drei stufen die haben den mystery mine
abknickt auf der 16 kommen wir zur nec
us- er seinen 74 millionen verloren
gerne zweiter wurde zur chemie oder
physik steht wenn man sie auf extreme
art anwendet als nächste auch das war
schon
ich liebe das wenn die chemie irgendwie
ich habe mir auch früher eigentlich ganz
cool gefunden aber das was wir in der
schule gemacht aber nie so cool wie die
chemie die man dann nehmen wir auf tik
tok sieht als nächstes kommen wir zu
einer person die schon lange vor der das
jetzt plötzlich so viele leute die
damals irgendwie im fernsehen hat social
media bringt auch nix ohne scheiß auf
einmal jeder ist hier unterwegs
will smith hat aber auch ein riesiges
produktionsteam hinter seinen tecdax
aber die videos sind trotzdem crazy oder
dein bett auf diesen
weiter geht's mit nick lucia norcom
länder lukas millionen follower hat
sondern auch mit einem clip mit über 370
millionen views läuft auf platz 14 der
meister schotten tech talks aller zeiten
landes
[Musik]
auf der t
was hat denn da jetzt gemacht
soll also ich kann das komplett
verstehen wenn der videos abgeben wo
wirklich in die kreative idee ist oder
wo leute sich mühe gegeben haben oder so
und das versuche ich ja selber auch beim
entdeckt doch so ein bisschen zu machen
dass es jetzt nicht irgendwie so ich
mache lip sync sich zu dem song aber das
verstehe ich halt oft nicht wie so was
dann ab gehen kann aber ich gehöre eben
nicht das jetzt irgendwie sagt bruno
ganz ich mache kein auge
der 13 uhr landet nun ein techniker den
die meisten von euch mit sicherheit
der auch in dieser liste auftauchen wird
nabil amer
mit der wieder lockerer 34 mal
auftauchen mit über 270 millionen views
ist das hier um eines seiner
erfolgreichsten videos
[Musik]
er wird um das klingt aber das ist genau
das was ich meine das sind einfach
kreative dumme kurze prägnante ideen die
jeder direkt checkt völlig zu recht mit
drin und das ist auch der sinn von tik
tok man muss ich nicht das wir
produzieren oder keine ahnung wie viel
geld da reinstecken aber das ist einfach
stark bevor wir weiter mit dem nächsten
klick machen darf natürlich auch in der
top 20 der erwarb das ist diese kevin
prince los und dann kommt so eine katze
daran die top 10 und hatten wir nun mit
einem weiteren superstar ein der vor tik
tok absolut unwahr und zwar dessen ray
williams 86 millionen verloren ist sie
mittlerweile eine der größten in fluren
zur in der welt ich will auch da nichts
falsches dagegen sagen so soll jeder mit
dem bekanntwerden was er will aber die
macht ja eigentlich auch nichts oder die
shaker bisschen und macht so lip sync
und
also ich will nicht sagen dass ich jetzt
viel mühe mir geht aber es ist halt so
viele leute auf der plattform ticker die
hat wirklich kreativ sind und sich geist
krank wie man einfach nicht den erfolg
haben den sie an den ihr eigentlich
zusteht ihr erfolgreichstes video hat
außerdem unfassbare 303 millionen
aufrufe karina ch
sie stellt ihr handy dahin in einem
leeren haus und macht ein bisschen
was kabila der übrigens sogar über
122 millionen follower hat kann das
sogar noch um 14 millionen ja so läuft
wieder einmal hoch los sie stellt ihr
einfach einen fuß vor
das ist diese asiatische content machen
so oft solche sketche wo man sich
einfach irgendwie so denkt hey
hey platz acht belegte die momentan wohl
heißeste musikerin der welt via
außerhalb von tik tok auf vielen kanälen
ich wusste dass politik zukunft ist
billig ihr meist gesehenes video auf tik
tok hat jedoch erstaunlich wenig mit
musik zu tun
sowas kasse hat aber auch in not bringen
wenn du schon bekannt bist noch die
nummer 7 macht einem ebenfalls gute
laune und hat darüber hinaus bahre
381 millionen views die sache es aber
da könnt ihr mich wirklich beim wort
nehmen ich habe schon oft sachen gesagt
die ich nachher anders gemacht habe und
das ist auch durch bei jedem menschen so
dass man mit 16 andere dinge sagt die
man damit 21 wiederum anders sieht oder
so aber ich werde niemals meine kinder
gegen wir öffentlich zeigen und das
macht ja gefühlt jeder influenza ich
will eigentlich videos von den perez in
dubai was an sich schon schlimm genug
ist dass sie da überhaupt wohnen und das
alles supporten und die film dann ihre
kinder beim windelwechseln halbnackt
oder wieder auf die fresse fliegen oder
so schnell wieder vor die kinder sind
der zehn jahre älter und dann irgendwie
kommen sogar auf weiterführende schule
und dann wissen alle von den leuten mit
denen du willst wie du dich als kind auf
die fresse kriegt das oder so das ist
dass das das wird so schrecklich sein
wie sie kinder das finde ich so
schrecklich das ist extrem süß ja aber
was das alles für folgen haben wird für
die kinder das weiß man hat noch nicht
bella protsch misst dagegen als
influenza in deutlich bekannter und
ihren über 80 millionen verloren eine
der größten nummern im tik tok game
erfolgreichstes video mtb dabei sogar
unglaubliche 632 millionen views in das
verstehe ich halt aber auch nicht
und dann halt diese kamera die darauf
das dauert halt zehn sekunden zeit ihre
wie du gepusht wie es auf dieser
plattform die top 5 beginnt mit einem
tech talk der zwar nicht ganz so viele
follower watch oder kabila einmalig den
resigniert sehr der vor allem durch
erstaunliche illusionen weltbekannte
dran ist hat mit seinem video in dem er
wände so streicht das andere denken sie
würden durch eine tür gehen unglaubliche
659 millionen views erzielt wird ist
somit verdient in den top-5 wichtig
kraft
kommt erstmal an
king machte kranken sachen fast 300
millionen mehr views und damit knapp an
marke landet als nächstes video von ihm
dieses mal verwandelt er ein wasserglas
in ein stück kuchen
die hälfte
das einzige was ich kann das ich sag
explosion
wow
cool und auch platz drei wird von
säckingen belegt dieses mal spielt er in
seinem badezimmer verstecken und knackt
damit die milliardenmarke dieses video
haben sich also umgerechnet alle
menschen aus europa und nordamerika
zusammen mindestens einmal angesehen
becker
platz zwei
es gehört allerdings ein kleines kind im
innenhof aber laut geschrieben der 2009
10 ein weihnachts videos hochlud das
mittlerweile unglaubliche 1,7 milliarden
mal angesehen wurde
ich verstehe die ursachen nicht
das war kein furz das war mein fuß auf
meinem stuhl kommen wir zum großen
finale nun zu platz eins und damit
zumeist geschaut und ex gak wieder da
jetzt wie angekündigt ist auch dieses
video von sekt king am 9 dezember 2009
10 einen clip online stellte der seitdem
geschichte geschrieben hat mittlerweile
wurde er nämlich atemberaubende 2,2
milliarden mal angesehen ist sehr king
so brutal auf der plattform wenn ich das
mal eingehen sagt kliem ich hatte denen
gar nicht so geisteskrankheit auf dem
schirm der hat ja auch nur 66 millionen
follower wenn man das mit anderen
vergleicht wie er dessen ray oder wie
dieser kabuler keine ahnung was die sind
ja deutlich größer als der king halt ab
das sind gold
ist das auch gold sind abonnent zu sein
von diesen kanal liegen freude der welt
das heutige die gefahr dass auch gern
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
da abonniert meinen kanal einfach und
klickt auf die glocke denn man konnte er
die nachricht übungen
ich kann nicht mehr reden